so somewhat odd thing happened to me a
couple of months ago I lost my wedding
ring I was in one of those um what do
you call it uh a divorce and now I have
to find somebody new which is easier
said than done because I was married for
so long I have nothing I have no game I
don't know where the stadium is anymore
because I am I'm so trained as a husband
you know that's all I know I'm just
gonna be staggering up to women in bars
excuse me I uh I saw you sitting there
all by yourself and I just thought you
might have a long list of chores and
errands you wanted me to do
maybe tomorrow I'll come by your place
and drive your mom to Target and when I
get back you can be angry at me because
I didn't realize something you thought
[Applause]
I'm honestly my ex-wife is fantastic we
get along great
we have children so you have to be an
adult about that stuff that's why I'm
wearing a vest but here's the weird
thing that happens with children when
they get about 4 or 5 years old their
baby teeth get loose and they come out
and you take the tooth and you put it in
the pillow and then you take and you put
a dollar and put the tooth over there a
couple months later it happens again
another dollar put the tooth over there
and then after a couple of months you
have this weird little collection but
you can't get rid of it it's literally a
part of your child
I guess it's so later on in life when
they've grown up and moved on you can
sit alone in a dirty bathrobe and sift
your fingers through an envelope of
human teeth hi Ricky its dad not much to
report just sitting around playing with
your teeth
[Applause]
but I was afraid with my kids that they
would grow up and go away that's the big
fear when you're divorced for a man my
kids are gonna grow up and I'm gonna be
left to die alone that's the male fear
and a divorce my kids are gonna grow up
and I'm gonna be left to die alone and
the more I thought about that and really
analysed where it came from inside me I
realized that for the longest time one
of my big goals in life was to die in
front of my children where did that come
from
hey kids let me tell you what Christmas
was like when I was a kid see we used to
I'm gonna call nine-one-one no you don't
you stay right there and you watch me
die all eyes on dad see the light
leaving my eyes that see an external
grip of death closing in on my existence
oh you could give me some of your youth
but no you just like your mother you
don't you
I only hope that when I do die I have
the presence of mind to summon whoever
is with me down to my bedside so I can
say in those last moments I buried two
million dollars underneath you have to
time it just right
otherwise you have to lie there and
pretend that you're dead well I'm going
to start the gross work on the internal
organs why don't you prepare the
embalming fluid I really should say
something but that joke was so funny
[Applause]
you